c'est des tas a confirmé la suspension
de l'autorisation du burkina dans les
piscines municipales de grenoble
camouflet pour le maire de grenoble eric
piolle est le conseiller le ministre de
l'intérieur gérald darmanin lui s'en est
félicitée une victoire dit il pour la
loi séparatistes pour la laïcité et au
delà pour toute la république en réalité
donc il ya eu un arrêté préfectoral qui
a suspendu la décision avec ensuite eu
un examen au conseil d'état qui a
confirmé l'arrêté préfectoral donc on
peut arrêter ce genre de mesure
délirante éternel débat qui ça dérange
qu'on fasse du crawler habillé en même
temps vraiment je
vais pas parce que on paie très
critiqués parce que wanda lessard fait
etc on peut être très critiqué dans un
sens inverse parce qu'on est couverte et
c'est moi je pars du principe où chacun
fait ce qu'il veut la liberté c'est
d'être comme on a envie et c'est là où
il ya un problème en france c'est qu'on
dit pour la liberté on n'a pas droit
burqini mais en fait de la liberté si
cette femme elle a envie d'aller à la
piscine couverte qui la dérange qui à
partir du moment où moi elle m'oblige
pas à me couvrir c'est moi si j'ai envie
d'y aller avec mes mes seins refaits j'y
vais comme ncl envie d'y aller couverte
elle fait ce qu'elle veut en fait non
c'est ça la mise à feu alors alors alors
je suis pas sûr que la comparaison soit
voilà la bonne âme est vrai mais en
revanche on voit ce que j'ai appris
quand même essayer bleus et que le
burkina a été inventé en 2004 à dire
nous ça allait oui c'est donc pas
forcément un voilà un vêtement
ancestrales quant à la les gérants du
voile qui a été porté depuis voilà des
siècles c'est pas du tout dans le coran
c'est pas du tout quand donc ça n'a
vraiment rien à voir oui mais ce qui est
intéressant dans ce que dit magali c'est
qu'ils avaient évoqué une éventuelle
autorisation du burkini avec
l'autorisation de faire du topless alors
c'est l excès de pudeur d'un côté et
l'ex et d'impudeur de l'auteur que ça
n'a rien à voir puisque le burqini ne
dérange personne par définition là où le
te plaise peut choquer peut-être des
enfants qui sont là qui ont pas envie de
voir des gens et partiellement
mais bien sûr
en tout cas c'est dommage le burkina ne
dérange personne et si ça pouvait
permettre à certaines femmes qui
aujourd'hui ne peuvent pas sûr on était
celui ci passe d'y aller ça aurait été
bien de l'autoriser le topless en
piscine municipale vous vous allez en
famille et vos enfants c'est un peu plus
déranger un peu plus dérangeant winky
eric le maire de grenoble en fait sous
prétexte d'être un anti raciste c'est
lui qui attisent la haine parce que
c'est de la provocation de faire ça est
ce que vous entendez des des manifs de
deux femmes qui veulent être en burqini
ça concerne 20 personnes en france à lui
il met sur sur la table un sujet dont
tout le monde se fout et en plus de ça
si on parle du burkina en lui-même au
maroc c'est interdit et dans plusieurs
pays arabes on ne peut pas avoir le
burqini donc pourquoi venir mettre un
sujet sur la table dont vous encore une
fois personne ne dit on veut aller en
burqini donc là c'est m de pointé du
doigt encore les musulmans pour qu'ils
aient un débat dessus alors que leur
vrai tout le monde s'en fout tout le
monde s'en fout quand vous êtes en
baissé en belgique derrière moi je ne
fais jamais apithy
[Rires]
c'est pas en belgique il ya bien des bd
piscine municipale en belgique oui
absolument
beaucoup de monde qu'ils font
je ne peux pas répondre à cette question
benjamin je ne je sais qu'il ya eu un
débat aussi concernant le burqini mais
je ne suis pas à même de pouvoir vous
dire ce qu'il en est en angleterre la
reine se baignent comment alors ah bah
sachez que buckingham palace par exemple
très peu de gens le savent mais ne
possède une piscine à trabzon privé
voile ouverte couverte absolument pour
que l'on ne voit jamais voilà l'art et
non en petit magne de malades on se dit
qu'il ya essentiellement trois personnes
qui fréquentent cette piscine à savoir
bao georges louis et charlotte les
enfants de madame et de quelques cadors
maritimes cet endroit delphine oui alors
sur cette affaire alors sur cette
affaire effectivement les gens doivent
être libres mais d'un côté comme de
l'autre voilà moi je suis pour que si
les femmes veulent être en topless
d'ailleurs comme les hommes ils peuvent
le faire mais à montsalès oui oui c'est
bien moi je met pas deux par jeu mais
vous devriez de poche devraient
le maillot de bain on va très bien le
une pièce je les ai vus alors le une
pièce pour les garçons avec le petit
shorty qui remonte à laver à ambiance
une fervente revient très fort sapscq
absolument ok il a les dernières
tendances toujours plus rien sur ce
sujet non non présent on sent que l'on
sent que c'est quand même un petit peu
touchy le sait très bien ce salaire